[Aplausos]
[Música]
somos una isla
no hay nada más que un pedazo de hielo
que está navegando en denunciar
y vamos a ver una foto que ilustra el
tope de lo que es una isla hay mucho más
debajo de lo que no se ve este otro otro
ejemplo de otro haysbert poco más
pequeño
pero no nos vemos engañar lentes porque
lo que está debajo de un potencial
increíble y estoy hoy aquí para hablar y
tati de eso
cuando yo empecé a hacer lucha olímpica
inicialmente no me gustaba mucho el
deporte porque pensaba que eso era
cálido es color a don luís y mi mente yo
tenía algo muy diferente poco a poco fui
aprendiendo de lo que era el deporte un
deporte de combate me fue gustando pero
lo más que a mí me gustó de la lucha
olímpica fue que para mí se convirtió en
un escape escape de las calles porque
era un niño y en travieso me gustaba
estar en la calle compartiendo con los
amigos con la gente en las calles pues
tuve muchas cosas drogas muertes
este robo excederá a ceder
y como yo crecí sin papá papá muere a
los 6 años en una operación
pues realmente yo no tuve muchos modelos
en mi vida fuera de diga más bien tuve
muchos modelos y yo me aferré a la lucha
olímpica
específicamente la disciplina y fui
trabajando fui trabajando y fuimos los
mejores luchadores de puerto rico- muy
rápido ya los 16 años yo estaba en los
eeuu
con la familia mike y de villois gracias
a ellos pues tuve la oportunidad echar
palante y me acuerdo de los retos manos
sabe el inglés que muchas veces uno
aprende no me caso básico pollito
ventanas
y más o menos y no me sé la canción
completa pero
para que vean que es que los retos
fueron difíciles con lo que estaba ahí a
veces para pedir un vaso de agua yo como
le digo esa gente un vaso de agua lleva
con lo que es bueno por y la lengua se
entiende yo cogí un vaso de agua y yo lo
público
y ahí yo me entendía y poco a poco pues
pues nos fuimos entendiendo muchos retos
la cultura la comida pues yo me aferré a
la disciplina que hay que hacer pasar
muchas horas estudiando que lo que hace
es entrenar duro y eso mismo hice
termine siendo el mejor atleta de todo
eeuu mi peso y esos móviles puestos para
llegar a michigan state university
me aferré de nuevo a la disciplina pero
que hay que hacer cosa y tutoría de
noche de día todas las horas pues eso
mismo dices entre duros fuimos luchado
el de todo eeuu a nivel universitario
campeón de la en su ley
actualmente estoy luchando
internacionalmente y he sido subcampeón
y hablo un poco del olimpia de olimpiada
que tiene un punto de medalla
olímpica
y este cuento brevemente de mistura
rápido para qué
porque quizás porque quizás aquí hay
alguien que dice malo pero está hablando
hoy de potencial
pero tú ha tenido éxito en toda tu
carrera de principio a fin
y yo no puede ser la persona si es
verdad esa persona puede decir es que se
lo tuyo hacia tus potenciales o lo que
tú eres tú eres luchador olímpico malo
todo existe para eso y lo puedes ir
verla o le puedo decir bueno no me mete
en una caja que yo soy un ice world es
mucho más de lo que lo puede apreciar y
para mí estimasen ilustra claramente lo
que es una y sobre lo que la gente no
puede ver muchas veces hasta uno mismo y
estaba al agua todo ese potencial que
está ahí en la lucha olímpica es
simplemente un pedacito una fracción
algo bien pequeño y el resto donde está
cómo lo desarrollamos
para mi potencial es la habilidad que no
ha sido expuesta el poder sin explotar
capacidad no utilizada
en sí es todo lo que tú y yo somos que
todavía no ha sido revelado el depósito
que espera y mira está esperando pues el
revelado y maximizado como yo estoy
haciendo eso
pues quizá hay mucha forma de sacar tu
potencial etcétera etcétera pero
personalmente yo lo estoy haciendo a
través de la lectura número porque la
lectura porque como atleta
tú te fuerza y mantiene el cuerpo en
debes seis pasos tú trabajas duro para
que tú te las mejores condiciones para
que no esté descansado como mi mamá dice
ahora tienes que entrenar para que no dé
vergüenza a veces
no lo dice jocosamente no
y como tú lees cuando tú lees el cerebro
empieza a activarse y es una la forma
que nosotros necesitamos nuestro cerebro
y cuando yo me acuerdo que no tenía ha
habido yo nada ese lectura y empecé a
leer a leer la letra empezarán a salir y
yo me imaginaba todo eso mi cerebro
empezó a pensarlo un poco diferente
y yo me di cuenta la textura me ayudó a
mí para hacer mejor mejores preguntas
que el punto nombró dos nosotros tú y yo
tenemos muchas preguntas pero muchas
veces no nos atrevemos a hacerlas las
preguntas
destapa en nuestra curiosidad
y vamos con lo que tiene un amigo que
estaba uniendo un formulario que iba en
un país que soy muchos papeleos
el medio franco y entusiasta tantas
preguntas manos y vídeos
bueno pero aprender yo tengo una hombre
por dentro que quiero aprender y sacar
todo ese potencial que está ahí porque
no sabía que estaba y originalmente
y preguntas que quizás yo me estoy
haciendo como
porque realmente es que yo lo mucho
realmente que está debajo de todo eso
son pregunta que tú te sientas bueno
quizás alguien aquí en la audiencia se
está preguntando
será hablar lo que dice franklin gómez
de que yo tengo un potencial que todavía
no lo descubierto la verdad es porque yo
no veo nada
tiene preguntas más filosófica por qué
estoy aquí en la tierra
cuál es mi propósito en esta vida
dios me ama
preguntas menos estrés si gano
ahora me gustaría tocar me gustaría
aprender a tocar el piano mira qué
belleza qué belleza y siempre me gustaba
cómo se escucha el sonido podréis
aprender a tocar el piano y yo llama con
lo que yo llegaba iba a los lugares
donde vendía un piano y lo veía cómo
estaba cómo se escuchaba yo creo que el
piano es una ilustración de cómo todo
este proceso empieza con la información
y profundiza con las preguntas empezar a
tocar
[Música]
y así es así
es así bien feo y poco a poco tú sabes
la escala los tonos y vas puliendo
[Música]
se va soltando lo sostenido y tú sigue
i
para suavizando poco a poco
[Música]
y es un ejemplo sencillo de lo que este
otro potencial poco a poco barrido y va
no puedes desarrollando poco a poco me
gustaría compartirlo otras otras cosas
muchas cosas que puedo hacer igual que
poco a poco el estado ha estado
descubriendo pero no tengo todo el
tiempo
tenemos potencial tengo que hablar de
carácter porque porque otro potencial va
de la mano con el carácter otro carácter
son valores y principios que no ayudarán
a tomar decisiones morales va llega el
momento en que tú
hasta el solo nadie te va a ver tú
tienes que tomar decisiones que va a
afectar lo que está el frente que está
atrás que está a tu lado que va a hacer
nuestro carácter y tiene que ver
con nuestro sentido de identidad no
tiene margen de sí mismo nosotros acá
eso del vecino de que está al lado de tu
papá y tu mamá de la lucha olímpica un
texto de una experiencia en el pasado
que quizás de marco en sí cuál es el
punto de referencia que no cambia la
cual tú puede anclar tu identidad y la
suma de todo eso este es tu carácter
tu potencial te puede llevar a la cima
pero tu carácter es lo que lo va a
mantener ahí
termino con el titanic quien vio la
película quien conoce todo el casi todos
nosotros conocemos las películas quizás
otros leído el barco más avanzado más
lujoso de ese tiempo en 1912 estamos
ubicados estamos navegando en el océano
y qué pasa
que hay una y schubert y un los
tripulantes pues se dará cuenta lo
notifica alerta y la gente como
lo subestiman esa ley está varias varias
veces
y todos saben la historia tratan de
evadir el ice bear pero eventualmente no
pudieron completamente y se hunde mucha
gente muere hasta lo en alto dicaprio
que no sabemos si se debió morir o no
entonces mi pregunta es cuál fue el
problema aquí yo creo que el problema
fue que a ellos se le olvidó la verdad
de lo que era una y saber yo creo que
hoy yo estoy aquí en este círculo rojo
para con like thé a ti a mí de que somos
una isla de que hay mucho más de lo que
luego puede ver un potencial increíble
está en tus manos y en mis manos
explotar todo este potencial que tenemos
así que damas y caballeros vamos a
fuerza no es el valiente
[Aplausos]